okay hmm for people who are joining our
livestream we are talking about a new
function repository and about how one
submits things to the function
repository and let's start off by just
having a quick look at the current state
of the preliminary function repository
so here we go what are some examples
here that actually work do they all work
I think they fit our so let's say color
to hex for example so and now we have
clicked a copy on this output or we
don't yet have click just on the implant
is only the inputs I think given that if
we really have and I think this is a
pretty useless have we decided we're not
having this this initial and out thing
because I think that's what we've
decided yeah this one hasn't been
updated to the latest convention but I
think the first example will be actually
using to think okay so this cool okay so
this is the basic scheme for the
function repository and what we are now
discussing is how the submission looks
like for that and here I just says
coming soon that's rather uninspired
um okay are we really gonna use these as
the categories and now know that that's
based on you know reference homepage and
we've we've come up with a different
list but I think I have a different
meeting to review that okay all right so
the subject here maybe we should look at
the old can I can I pull up the old
function repository submission notebook
yeah you can use our dog food to do that
you can do a resource function of create
resource notebook amazing
and then it takes argument function as a
string beautiful beautiful food um
unfortunately I think the results here
looks like dog food too but that's
different this year okay so so the issue
is there's it's way too complicated to
do this so let's take a look at what
we've got over here um by the way if
somebody has is generating a lot of
background noise on this some audio
no not okay um all right what are we
gonna do with things which are meta
versus things cuz here it's very obvious
what's matter
and what's actual um and by the way do
the eyes work here yes
nice okay all right what are we gonna do
with the with the meta versus the you
know actual what what is that convention
for that well we've we've moved back to
the notion that everything in the
notebook is self-explanatory to the
degree you don't have to separate meta
from actual that much you know what we
did on the left was overwhelming we
thought right that the the meta aspects
were just seeming to make things too
complicated to move forward people are
comfortable using our technology at the
default notebook level right they see
that constantly that's how they interact
with us with them with their own work so
exploiting that is what we see on the
right keeping it fairly simple that way
you know everything's relatively obvious
all right we think it's obvious that
that's something like this I mean
shouldn't we put this somehow in some
kind of annotation that indicates that
that's not you know or what do we do
well well we could I don't like putting
the brackets because it implies then or
it makes people confuse thinking do I
have to leave the brackets right it it's
it's a convention we use internally a
lot but I don't think it's that common
to people okay the best way for people
to understand how to use the thing is to
see the example right so the view
example button you know maybe we can
feature that better but which for
example buttons right in the top right
it could stand out more obviously right
so but I assume there's an example there
so try that out and yeah let me just a
little bit okay but you know I think
Pete
learn by example as much as anything I
certainly do
and it's kind of like okay I think that
obvious - is to unclear what it actually
is so see the thing that concerns me is
the concept that you have to delete this
and put something else in is really
annoying to me
we had some tech for clicking or tapping
- the field would dismiss the initial
content yeah I mean in other words that
we do have templatized functionality so
soon as you click it becomes blank ready
for you to type we can do that I didn't
want to over engineer this page just yet
I felt like again keeping it simple for
starters is a good way to get going and
you know test how people react to it
rather than you know because is it it's
a little annoying to when you're just
clicking around trying things and it
disappears you know will cause it to
come back not with the current
implementation obviously if you opened
another version of the notebook it would
have all the fields okay let's look at
the demonstration submission thing which
again is very over it's pretty old and
yeah where is it
I'm not seeing here you're using their
version for some reason that doesn't
have it
not sure why if that was a Wolfram
desktop issue or not has somebody
chopped that down because that's
something that needs to get fixed it has
been raised with the appropriate teams
okay okay so here
so let's look at what we've got here
we've got this one which is pretty
horrific um I noticed that you know
we're saying your title here in this
case which is like my function right we
want to encourage the camel case in the
function right right and that it's not
spaced right okay so this could be
formatted in the exact same what the
heck is example here same thing
it's view example oh it's an example of
that but it's not an example of this oh
I see because this is optional anyway
right right well actually it wasn't
optional actually that was closed and it
had something in that okay but it had
been closed for some reason which is
rather confusing yeah I'm not sure why
there it is okay but so look while we're
at it let's standardize this because
this is just a notebook right there's
nothing right more elaborate than that
here and all we have to do to make this
the same type of thing is you know just
pull back I don't know what the styling
is here particularly do you know what
the styling is here is that the correct
styling but when you say correct it is
the way it was designed to look but its
styling that goes back a long time ahead
of the modern changes we've made toward
default style sheets okay fine so so
this could probably be the default style
sheet now the style we have on our
resource function one matches testing no
puts and template notebooks okay
yet another standard right I I don't
know I think you could still have a more
designed header tool the header should
be designed I think the rest of it if we
can avoid designing it would be better
and you know let's try to bring this
incor espanish with this okay yeah I
have no problem with that okay let's
look at the while we're at it at the
presumably this will do data if I say
data though will bring up the edges okay
is this working
this submission notebook
but if people find it confusing it works
but not for most people who try it
because they give up because it's
confusing okay yeah so we want to
revisit that I think with whatever we do
with the function notebook and see him
which I can translate it won't be as
direct a translation right so one of the
most important things here
yes I mean this dollar dollar object
business we are avoiding that here
because we're actually naming the
function yeah right um and yes I mean
what we are imagining is that this very
beautiful object okay so yeah I mean
this is
complicated what it's trying to do is
fairly complicated right there's an
inherent problem in most of these create
definition notebooks in that when you
get to defining examples you need the
thing to do the examples but you don't
have a thing yet because you're still
making the you're still defining you so
that's where that dollar dollar thinking
came in for data or in function we
avoided it because we can just have a
function with the same name and that's
not too big of a burden to have it have
the same name right well so in the case
of the data resource maybe we need a
simplified you know submission process
when people just have you know here's a
data set I'm giving it a name because a
lot of this complexity has happened with
additional content elements and things
like this yep yeah maybe you need to do
is to branch right at the top I mean and
all this stuff is also a big complicated
mess and arguably shouldn't be in this
notebook it should be in some kind of
additional button you press that goes
ahead and does something we write
whatever we come up with on function
that part can follow directly back into
data okay fine
okay well what one aspect of what we've
been talking about for function is is
getting people to submit things sooner
rather than later so to speak like get
them to do as much as they need even if
it's the most a minimal amount of stuff
to get something in the system and they
give them feedback in the form of you
know a landing not a landing page but a
shingle page or ever you want to call it
where they can see what they're doing in
reaction to what the server is giving
them but I don't know how effective that
would be for the data resource side of
things because I don't know how
automated all of that is and it looks
more complicated to me well it's pretty
much the same mechanism if we're using
the cloud deploying goal right I mean if
fundamentally what we do is we say let
people put in the minimal thing and then
see that it's incomplete and finish it
if that's the workflow we expect rather
than have everybody front-load
everything and you know submit the most
perfect thing
right and I like that first approach
better because I just don't think people
can get it right the first time ever
yeah
well that certainly has been our
consistent experience even in the
demonstrations project right
and the demonstration happening is
mercifully much simpler than these other
ones indeed it may not look it because
of all the instruction but you know
right and that's what we thought I mean
basically that should become you know
just to be clear you know in the case of
demonstrations this should literally
become let's go back to the where was
that I don't want these that I want um
you know I would imagine that this just
literally goes you know your title here
I mean it literally will look roughly
yes I don't think it should yeah I mean
the sections you know initially yeah
right right right it's just section and
section manipulate code well I think
just say manipulate right and we'll clap
the same kind of explainers as we think
are needed it the point being people
learn by doing and we want to encourage
them to do which is give it a shot you
know fill some stuff out submit and then
learn through the iteration of that
process
yeah I mean this is going to be
mercifully simple probably we're
expected to be
we could do here what we've done on the
other ones input some of these fields
like search terms and related links
under a single section as subsections
yes okay here let me just save this um I
mean I will give a shout out to the cool
trick we developed there on the
demonstrations notebook to put all of
that content you see on display within
style definitions so that the actual
notebook expression is incredibly
minimal I say that I mean you know like
if you're to go back to where you see
caption and and show the cell expression
for you know anybody looking at that
they might be surprised to see there's
nothing there except the style name yeah
that's interesting that it was a nice
nice effect you know nice feature sort
of thing of how our structured notebook
concept works quite well when you need
it to that way but in the end you know
it's a lot of content right well I mean
that's an interesting method for doing
structured notebooks which we're not
using but ok let's go back then okay so
then we please clean up this this thing
just so that we can see that we can do
it in a uniform way right
the yeah and I think with respect to the
data one um
yeah what a complicated thing I think we
can do do a pass like you say where we
have just a simple case of one piece of
data and then any other elements can
just be in a closed section lower down
kind of an advanced features section
I think we'd want to provide it all in
the same place so you don't have to you
know go back and forth between two
different notebooks or two that was
that's fine I think that's right I think
if you want to do it all up front you
can do it all up front but the advanced
features thing otherwise they'll come
back to you and say this stuff hasn't
been finished okay all right let's look
at the function repository then and what
we're actually doing here okay so this
definition should allow you know there
could be a subsidiary functions that are
defined here right yeah that's what the
description in the curly brackets is
trying to communicate in there more info
button okay it's fine fine well we'll
look at the actual text in there okay so
can we look at the ones that I've made
um just to understand you know how this
would relate
let me see
okay so here's a few that I've made um
let's say binary coded ternary okay so
um here we should have an information
thing well where do we want to put that
we want an information thing there that
tells them don't put a period at the end
if we don't want a period don't
capitalize don't put a period shall I
write some of the stuff out sure um I
mean style style tips maybe we want a
notion of style tips for all of them
yeah I think that's something we kept
out of the current the text that we put
into this notebook just because that can
can bloat the description a lot yes text
when you open the I button well if it's
formatted it might be easier to
understand right if there's a there's a
main text that says what it is
and then a stylistic notes hey I might
even be more inclined to put that on a
on a web page okay okay
and then with then what will we do we
would have something with arrows and
things pointing to things and say I
think that might make it more readable
you know an arrow saying diagramming it
you mean
diagramming a final one and saying you
know here's the yeah okay could be done
as a workflow right yeah I think that
gives us the the freedom of space you
know we could do some sort of table of
contents if we want it if it got big
enough but then it wouldn't you know
clutter up the fine and then we could
have in the header we could have
something that points to that thing that
opens that thing for people Oh Sandra
our live stream is say can't there be
automatic period deleting or some
function that's just applied to the text
cell it's a fair point I mean
we could do that there will be a
pre-flight for this oh yeah so what do
you mean that the question is is that do
we just do okay so this is another
question do we just delete the period or
do we tell the person I mean you know
because there could be a case in which
there was a genuine period at the end I
think we have to tell the person and let
them correct it because otherwise there
could be all kinds of crazy things that
would happen it affects how you write
the description so yes they should yeah
there are thousand places where we could
make decisions to be more automated and
hands-on but in general I think we
should cookie hello
a piece of advice that says this should
be this way right only also keep in mind
that you might be filling this out not
to submit it but glad to play it and
then who cares if there's periods you
can do whatever you want mm-hmm in other
words for your own use you're saying
right right you might not yeah it might
be for your own use you could have five
periods at the end and I won't care okay
this examples thing that needs to be
somewhat open I think and for goodness
sake we've got to have basic examples
and I think we've got to have the
sections I don't see why we wouldn't
have that I don't always understand the
sections but if you think our users will
then great they're all optional right
yeah well basically examples shouldn't
be optional no right but but the the
additional examples right and why aren't
these using command shift 7 which I hope
is going to be in version 12 can you
check on that Andre or whatever
who's Manu is here also could you please
check on that do you know what we're
talking about yeah I mean I certainly do
and I can explain to the guys later but
I wasn't sure we wanted to use that
style here okay Rick actually suggested
that Mike told them well I've never if
it's
I don't think we need to put it in here
right we need to put it in here we need
to get people used to using it I think
that's fine but I think if people just
do command seven and we'll treat it the
same fine in that yes yeah we can put in
there as I say can we please make sure a
man who can you make sure you check with
John Fultz and the other guys to make
sure that we're adding this I think
we're calling it code text correct okay
I mean it you should see it in your menu
if you're using a development version or
a current version of Mathematica should
have it actually what do you mean couple
you mean current current 1200 or current
no current eleven three but without the
shortcut I mean it's there but it
doesn't yes well I know we need the
shortcut I mean you show up in the style
menu and let's please make sure this
really happens okay so
all right so what are you gonna do here
so
I guess that's okay I mean you got to
explain to people how you do that how do
you do that right so one thing Rick did
that's really nice is if you select a
word right no this didn't look what the
typing of an enter didn't work
typing returned did not work Oh
works for me this I I created a new cell
here I don't know what it's doing it
should be the right cell I can I can
look into the enter thing not working
okay so now I could go this and I do
italics yes you can heal something like
that right click to do the actual don't
fine but italics will work yeah you can
do it Alex what do you mean right click
to do what what does right click do see
format as template input know what
template input me exactly all right yeah
so there's this all we've now there's
this all our internal tools that we've
had that no one knows how to use besides
us if we want to go through that
Herculean effort of communicating that
we can but yeah just supporting italics
makes sense to or just not make just let
them do it normal text undo what I mean
that's not going to be acceptable for
its what's displayed looks at our yeah
right but we can do the formatting as it
can we how do we know what's a literal
on what's not
when is doing all yeah I know wouldn't
wouldn't wouldn't it never be literal I
mean it's not there might be electrons
there might be something where you you
feed in I mean mostly that will have
start with an uppercase letter right so
I mean okay how is this supposed to work
is this so each one of these if I hit I
see that will do that that's okay that's
good
and by the way that should have a period
at the end right we've got a lot of
background noise here I don't know what
that's Bob's phone maybe yeah I'm sorry
I think it's my headset he'll
investigate okay okay all right so let's
take a look at my example over here
right
um
[Music]
if there is none they have to delete
that line correct they don't have to
we'll know it's the original template
and remove it you know yeah it
automatically ignores the default stuff
okay well so okay so let me try filling
this in a bit okay so can I now do a
generate here it won't work if you leave
it the name is my function though like I
was just saying if you leave it as the
default stuff it well what will it do
let me see what it does
I think that should say please give your
function a name
mannequins ants yeah um we are also
going to need you to surface every piece
of text that's in this thing
okay I can you guys yep
well this is nice this is very nice
what this is doing for preflighting
you
you
should we what do you mean no definition
found for this function oh I see yeah so
normally if you aren't creating it from
the notebook it would be fine if
something was undefined but this one I
think that would be a clear mistake
this mean results what is this alright
we sweeten into Scott we talked about
this the other day and this is the best
idea we came up with was creating a
results section at the bottom that has
the output of those buttons I'll put up
which buttons the button user said
generate it generates a resource
function what are you gonna do with that
resource function
I don't know does it run here yeah is
that that's dental work anywhere you can
copy and paste it you can do it everyone
with it but we need to put it somewhere
well that's not a good place for it I
don't think I mean yes it's a good place
but it's the wrong presentation of it
okay so
you
it seems like the results can have some
special formatting to separate it
visually from the rest are you gonna
substitute in here in the examples are
you going to substitute this in because
you could substitute in the whole whole
thing you could substitute the trainee
dim they need to find us anyway it's
never gonna be X comma Y all right think
I need to actually I understand but when
in here write this you could go through
and substitute for the word this
function you could substitute if you
want it to I'm not sure it's a good idea
I don't think this is the right thing to
do I think the right thing to do is to
generate a new notebook which has
everything substituted am i making sense
and Submission you know book or just a
new notebook that's like a report a new
notebook that's like a report that
doesn't have the eyes and things in it
that just shows this is what the this is
what would be submitted if you were to
submit it I see so it's a it's an
iteration that has a submit button on it
so that you could submit from it yes
there's nothing else and it's kind of
like saying is this what you want to do
write review yeah okay and so isn't the
cloud to play chingle a better preview I
I think so how do you see it in the know
we want we want a local notebook preview
which you already are generating see
what I'm saying I understand what is
what advantage that gives you over just
looking at the notebook that's already
in front of you oh because it's because
it will substitute in this function it
will substitute the function head into
all these places you know what I'm
saying
it's doing what you're doing here but
it's showing you what it's going to do
but it has to throw the template it
stuff away
yeah throw that stuff away and it
substitutes this in so you see what
you're getting in a notebook and there
has a submit button right I'm always a
big fan of encouraging the cloud
deployment as a way to see the way the
page actually ends up you can try and
using use it at that point okay so this
is very very weird the way that this is
that what we agreed it's going to look
like at the top I think this template
needs are some of the updates that went
into the website still there's a lot of
customizations in the public repository
are not on the user deployed thing you
know it's not gonna have that orange
branding that orange branding is part of
the published repository
okay let's go through this again but so
just real fast though Bradley you're
suggesting this shingle this web
deployed thing be what you are shown
instead of a notebook right and so
instead of having to click on the cloud
object it could go straight there after
every well look why don't you give it an
option that just says local notebook
well I don't even know what local does
what is local to it caches it in that
local object so you can use it
subsequent colonel sessions it's local
cache of the resource object
okay that's completely unclear to me I
mean that that's but that doesn't give
you documentation right now okay two
different things that are going on here
okay
one thing is a thing which is preview
you know resource notebook it's
basically one thing and the other thing
is deploy
and really there are actually three
things here locally to the cloud and
then you're gonna submit it to the
global function repository am I making
sense right we hit submit button over on
your right you might not see yeah I
didn't see it right and I I felt like
generate and this deploy could be
consolidated I thought maybe even submit
could be in that but there is something
to be said for the nice big submit
button being I don't think that that's I
think people are going to want to do um
if they submit from the preview and we
force that being processed then that's
okay then you don't have a submit button
here right you have to preview it first
you know which makes sense because
otherwise just gonna bounce back and say
it's alright yeah okay so let's go
through this again
do we have anybody from graphic design
here I don't think so
okay um maybe we should get somebody and
I think Jeremy some way to just get the
resource function to just start using it
is useful of course but we're going to
do that okay so okay this is completely
confusing can we get somebody if Jeremy
is available
okay soon um okay so I think Alex just
went off to go get him um
so let's review again so then this comes
back
maybe we want to say keyword 1 here
you
other related material makes sense
mm-hmm that's probably pretty redundant
with the more info we could probably get
rid of the more info which more info on
the links the more info drop down for
you
the the I circle I have no idea I
wouldn't know I would say there it's got
to say make it or cannot make it an
actual URL make it an actual make it a
hyperlink right right so it says URLs
are everything strapped okay okay I
think this is
reasonably and we could do the same
thing for the other repositories in
terms of the source and additional
information yeah um is it going to
pre-fill by default the author name now
will it do if you submit and if you
submit without an author name it will
bounce back and say we need an author
name now that that contributed by is
what you want to be the publicly facing
name I understand that but I'm saying if
you submit to the public repository I
contributed by it will bounce back I I
think we could accept it was that one
why not in that case or nothing like why
can't something just well if somebody
submits a good function but they don't
want their name attached to it what's
wrong with that that's fine then we've
got to say that in the then we got to
say you can clear that out
am I making sense sure sure but we
should at least you know bounce back to
them and say you didn't put something
there um okay if they don't touch it it
bounces back but if they delete it its
treated as an animistic
because yeah there's still be a
publisher ID tied to it but not a
human's name well the publisher ID is
for us it's not for them and it's not
for the world
polish ID is just so we can keep track
it's it's it's you know publicly
available information right now why why
because that's when we set it up that's
all we wanted that's what we decided on
I don't think we should do that useful
to see you know all functions or data
published by yeah I know but there's
username that it seems tenuous to me it
seems like an unnecessary piece of
complexity but I mean it's not clear how
you display it what are you gonna do it
to you UID isn't it
what is the publisher ID how well the
name is is and that's you know the hue I
D is behind their name alright okay fine
did we get Jeremy here by chance
yeah okay we are trying to design the
simplified less horrifying um
submission notebook for
the function repository that will follow
through to all the other ones okay okay
so I think what we want here
um this should follow the format of
things like
I see see that's a very muted header
here
is there a vertical bar there with
nothing on the right of it
anybody know I knew please check into
that chest area well maybe it's just
supposed to go on with the one on the
left like it's isolating that buttons as
different from the rest I don't think
it's right it looks wrong to me
okay so here
I think this should be
more dramatic branding do people agree
than this I think this is a different
case here absolutely
yeah I agree - I was expecting him any
reason this shouldn't just follow the
other repository designs I thought
that's what we were gonna do
no because the other repository designs
turned out to be unbelievably
complicated and we're just kinda giving
up on them well I think Jeremy's tedder
right styles visual styles I don't see a
problem with that yeah
the buyer that we don't want to follow
from dinner we don't want to agree with
all their styling we want to look like a
simple notebook but the header the
header it seems like that'll be
reasonable yeah although I think it
could be slightly simplified from this I
think they should all be all uniform
yeah so I think it should say
are we gonna call it resource function
no function repository I think we should
call it function repository definition
notebook I still think this workflow
where you create one and just use it
locally or to play to share it with your
colleagues without ever touching any
repository is it workflow we want to
encourage all right fine so what do you
want to do then you want to say then
then you want to actually call it
resource function definition notebook
resource function or function space
resource yeah all right okay but wait
for it to be possible you're gonna have
to format function resource differently
from definition notebook makes sense
Jeremy oh yeah yeah okay um okay let's
say then at this top part let's say for
the first thing there you know open
[Music]
example
how do we parse make this possible
because I didn't get what that was
that's an example of one of these
notebooks see completed example I've
considered sample as okay sample
definition notebook okay fine I think it
needs some iconography to make it clear
what it is okay then the next thing here
wants to be something that says um okay
preview I think you can just say preview
instead of generate and what it does is
it generates another notebook that is
the same thing and those are kind of
different pieces of functionality what
well okay so the the generate is similar
to running generate resource function
based on the content of this notebook
and it gives you just the resource
function block to find resource function
even write write to find resource
function and then you can use that blob
wherever okay wait wait wait wait so
within this local session it sets
everything up is that correct yes yeah
okay but it doesn't save it to the local
object store or anything like that right
L correct
I think that's what preview should do I
think preview should substitute as I've
said five times here it should
substitute every one of these blobs
right which gives you the actual name of
the you know and it gives you wherever
the clickable version of the you know it
should do the click to copy thing it
should make it so that the function is
available and you can go use it and
that's what preview does it makes
another notebook you could save if you
want to that is this thing but it's a
disembodied notebook that doesn't yet
have a place doesn't yet have a name and
so on I'm making sense you would never
replace the stuff in the definition
though right I'm sorry what in the
definition cells we wouldn't want to
replace a symbol or anything okay fine
fine fine that's fine well then maybe we
should remove the definition cells from
the preview
maybe the preview is really just a
notebook preview of what would be
deployed you get what I'm saying
yeah that seems reasonable to me and
that's that's the way of indicating that
the function has been defined and that
that blob can be used I'm a little bit
worried in that case if I saved the
preview notebook and then opened it in
another session it would not work that
is correct I mean what are we going to
do about that as soon as you have this
it's not gonna work in another session
so there's nothing really to be done
about that I mean if you really wanted
to go there you could save the
definition in a dynamic you know no
initialization for the notebook so when
you open it it initializes why don't we
just put a header at the top of the
preview that says definitions have been
made for this session only by making
sense well we could also store the
definitions in the notebook persistence
location so it would work at least in
that notebook he opened it later I think
that's super confusing
so I can you edit the examples in the
preview I wouldn't do that
I would I would make them uneditable
otherwise people will edit them and get
confused that they're not that starts
thing but this is when you get the blob
which is what you want in order to
create examples what are you talking
about
no you create examples just like this
right half the point of this was that
you would get the blob unless it's no no
no no no you see these with the blob in
them okay we're gonna run out of time
here and we really need to go through
what needs to happen here okay we need
to be generating the preview where you
see the blob in there
right you're not editing the examples in
the preview and the examples in the
source remain unblocked
that's what I would do any problem with
that
any problem with that no that's fine I
mean you're saying if this function for
the IMP refer them to evaluate and give
you outputs in the employee water in the
original notebook you still have to
change my function to this function so
that they give you the outputs you are
of course talking about I mean of course
you have to change yes of course you
have to do that but these are just
samples most things you type in will be
typed from scratch right we've got
limited time let's move on okay you
understand what to do with this preview
notebook yes and I recommend locking
everything in it yeah yeah I agree okay
okay now we want what is what should
deploy B what does deployed locally mean
means local cache of the resource object
and where's the documentation for it
resource object no no no no no no no no
where is documentation where how do you
see any documentation in that case you
know okay you could still ask for the
documentation from the blob you created
it it's your resource function you
probably know how to use it right I
think that case is going to be totally
obscure to people I mean I don't know
why I mean that's a case where you don't
have any documentation you don't have a
place to put documentation but it is
something which is locally available in
your system right how do you Nauti ever
use any file or a local object well it's
not that's not it's not intended to be
used this is intended for export
purposes I don't think we should make
this a very visible option I mean we can
make it an obscure special case but I
don't think people are going to care
about it and I think it's just going to
confuse people and when you say public
is it really public well we thought we
made it public since we don't have cloud
to play with more arguments since we're
putting in a button yeah hey wait wait a
second wait a second wait a second wait
a second wait a second
yes use cloud deploy you can take the
resource function which would have been
given to you by generate here and you
can use cloud to play the resource
function and then set whatever versions
you want but this is a dummy button that
deploys to an anonymous cloud object
paths with public permissions okay we
show people how to do this okay and the
people who deploy if people want to
deploy it to a no one named location
this isn't gonna do it for them right
there's a workflow on how to do that
well how do you do it how do you do it
from here what do you do you type cloud
deploy at the end of this notebook
somehow you would hit the generate
button and then cloud deploy that blob
that comes from a witch blob this one
here yes okay well maybe we should
explain that in the preview maybe we
should have an area in the preview for
things to try
no deployment no no I that's not right
the employment options you know that
it's you know we kept it out of the form
because it was making the form too busy
but in the preview maybe that's
reasonable that there's a section that
says okay you made this thing in here
your deployment options if you think the
most important deployment is to a public
well I I would not even address the
question whether it's public okay
I wouldn't address it here it's going to
an anonymous UUID doesn't matter just
say but that way if you know it's public
you can share it I think this is
document that somewhere but not I think
it should say why don't we say
or share save is I think not quite the
right term okay then let's say deploy to
cloud and then we've got submit to
repository right and you'll at work you
have a mouse over that says it's what it
says what you're saying but it's
deploying publicly to an anonymous UUID
yes but so you're thinking there would
be a submission option from this source
notebook and that same submission option
is on the preview as well I think sorry
I think so and then what comes back so
here I like Rick your thing where it
where it Flags things with red when they
don't work right yeah and then okay so
then the end result of this you can save
this notebook wherever you want now how
do you get back this notebook from the
blob can you recover the submission
notebook definition notebook rather not
yet okay so that's an important yeah
that's something we're gonna have soon
okay all right fine it would it would
have to be the resource object blob not
the function blob yeah yeah cuz you
can't okay so where are you showing
people okay so somewhere at the top of
the preview and the final deployed page
where is the resource object from here
that was one of the first examples we
had but it's not that's not gonna work
as an example it's not the right thing
to have an example right I was only have
a footer why don't we have a footer that
gives the resource object okay and maybe
it can give maybe it can have an opener
that opens out to show some of these
examples
am I making sense
a footer at the like actual footer below
the all the metadata everything else or
last example type I'm kind of thinking
it would be nice to just have a box on
the page that has this information so
that you easily can copy/paste the the
resource object to use it
am I making sense yeah which we should
try to get a mock-up of that so that on
the page there would be what would it be
and this would be the cloud deploy page
and auditory yes yes yes you know maybe
it should have just a thing here that
says resource information
I prefer that for sure and then then it
gives the click to copy version of the
resource object and then somehow it
could just list the resource object name
bracket definition notebook bracket a
couple of other things always click to
copy indicating you know give it because
pretty obvious what it's going to do if
you say the resource object bracket
definition notebook it's always gonna
generate that there's no point in
generating it right here that makes
sense
yep mmm okay all right in the okay so do
we have a path forward with all this
sounds like it yes okay and as examples
right so so I don't know what Rick's
pre-flight type stuff does like for
sizes of graphics and things like this
it's pretty simple right now doesn't do
a lot of checking something we wanted to
keep what's the pre-flight stuff what we
do yeah we do um so when you say
graphics you're concerned people will
produce giant outputs that we have to do
something about yeah we just have to
deal with that um look what we should do
obviously we want you know an increasing
set of rules that will cause things to
okay so what is the workflow so people
press for the repository they say submit
to the repository obviously if they're
things that are just unsubmitted all
because something wasn't filled out it
will complain immediately otherwise what
will happen is it will send them back
something saying I mean well if they
submit to a repository without having
them preview when they also get a
preview I mean preview should do the
pre-flight as would submit to repository
wouldn't it yeah I guess are you saying
submit to repository bypasses I don't
think it should get preview that preview
they there's a name - there's a version
-
review um if you don't care about
preview because you know what you're
doing then you have this other method as
much yourself right
but then what comes back okay so in the
preview case in the case where you're
doing your own deploy to cloud you get
to see what is or isn't there if you if
you I mean it won't give you a big essay
about what isn't isn't there I'm making
sense yeah if if you submit to the
repository then we humans or machines
are gonna give you back something that
tells you what isn't there that makes
sense to people
so the pre-flight occurs with the submit
to repo but it does not occur with the
preview it's kind of what you're saying
I guess right yeah the full preflighting
I mean maybe we are want to give them an
option to do that give them options we
have to keep it straightforward all
right fine well then submit to
repository we'll do the pre-flight and
we'll tell them what happens um but then
then what we send them back for the
pre-flight is basically a version of the
definition notebook with annotation do
you agree so that they can edit it well
soda little modify this submission
notebook right there like Rick's things
I won't it won't be that particular
thing will it will it be Rick what what
should be done with that should we
modify this particular if you say submit
to repository is it going to modifies
it's gonna make the pre-flight comments
in this notebook I guess it can it sure
that I think so yeah all right okay fine
okay okay that's good and maybe we
should have a different level of
warnings so like a warning as opposed to
an error yeah but look by the time
that's happened by the time you're going
to the repository this is no longer
optional right right so how is that
going to be handled
can someone you say submit to repository
that's gonna then edit this notebook to
change the thing that says optional
yeah that's doable Oh
let's take out the word optional there
because I think it's confusing too let's
take out the word optional and let's
have a thing there that we can say
contributed by is anything else not
optional for submission I don't think we
like it without some of these other
things
okay so additional information what
about the tests for example we need
tests
we took out that section it was too
complicated
we'll need tests under this source and
additional information we'll need tests
okay they don't have to fill it out if
they don't want to and up here it can
say optional except for repository
submission something like that needed
for some repository submission makes
sense
we're going to need tests how would we
get away without tests any idea we there
are people involved in this process no I
understand we want tests so that we can
do regression testing on their functions
in subsequent versions we've been
through this like 25 times
we need that don't take it out so how do
tests differ from the examples let's
just say that you know I've got a
function I'm giving you an example
it's use I don't want to tell you more
because it doesn't do more you know so
why do I have to fill out a test as well
okay it's optional right you're right it
should be optional we can test from the
examples but we do need the cable
for people to do that I think well let's
put it in that it's optional
I think it's an optional thing it's
fines but yeah right okay so we're
getting rid of this down here and the
way that you get to see these things is
in the preview the preview I know all of
the deploying submit options will
generate the preview notebook so
honestly I think I think this is a bad
idea
I think we should there's the easiest
thing to do is just get the resource
function
you shouldn't have to generate a whole
nother notebook or a cloud object or
something like or resource submission
there should give me a way to just get
the resource function and use it well go
to suggestion how to do that generate
button nobody's ever gonna understand
what that does or we can change it yet
create maybe so understand what it does
I mean it's like like why would you want
that what why does it matter that you're
generating I mean people want to see
what what good does it do you until the
thing has been committed somewhere to
the cloud or to a local object who could
care nobody cares what the resource
object is do they I mean we have all
this integration of resource function in
the Wolfram language that you can
everything that were documented on
research function page thank you I think
part of Stephens point is if you've
defined a function like like this
function right use it
you you you just defined it use it for
yourself right what if you want to do a
what if you wanted to cloud apply to a
specific paths what if you want to you
know use the blob itself in in a
notebook that you're creating that you
just want save as a notebook most of the
time why would it ever look unless you
saved this in a persistent location it's
not gonna work right what if you want to
save in a persistent location okay well
then why don't you just do it I mean
you've got cuz you don't have to block
you don't you don't have the resource
function you can't just do it without
generating this whole there notebook
okay well okay so
then then what you want to say is that
there should be a button here that says
that basically gives you that as a
separate notebook probably gives you
this thing here and you can do what you
want with it so we could say okay look
what we could do is something that says
generate resource object
pretty obscure but a private one right
it's just for you several more sayings
we could we could say deploy to notebook
it's a long term know if you don't wanna
put in this notebook you won't put in a
different oppa no just generate resource
object is at least look if we
that as a separate one of these a kind
of a subsidiary thing generate resource
object people who really know what
they're doing and want to do that will
use it
okay and other people will not because
it's somewhat obscure and generate
resource object I think should make a
new notebook that contains some
annotated thing that just says here's
the resource object I don't even know
what the resource object is is it local
or is it and here we would say local
object or cloud object right that would
be a pulldown right now like like this
one that says local object or cloudy ok
well then so there's three cases there's
three cases that you want might have and
they're under a delimiter in that same
menu of choices okay it's under this
this thing would have a a menu that says
um okay let's say it's local to this
session let's say for this session only
local
this computer or
in my cloud account I will functionally
be equivalent to flight a cloud well but
it isn't actually equivalent because
what it's gonna do here it's a for my
cloud account I agree it will be what's
that - private instead of public though
yeah that makes sense is a distinction
so I like this it's much more clear and
is that a separate button yeah the
generate resource object will be a
separate button of fourth you know so
this would be open sample definition
notebook and then vertical bar or
something right and I'll preview out and
then generate resource object could be I
don't know where generate resource
object goes maybe it goes before maybe
it goes between open sample definition
notebook maybe open sample definition
notebook goes at the end I kind of want
people to go right to that though we'll
play around with this it's gonna when we
see a design it will impact where the
buttons go so alright okay and various
people on a live stream are saying
please make the data repository
submission simpler yeah that's why we're
having this live stream we're
advertising and now we're obligating
ourselves so they're yes right yes we
had another question why don't use a web
form or the answer to that is because
you don't get all of the there's well
okay so
question a valid question is can one do
this in the cloud with a cloud notebook
could this be a cloud notebook probably
could be we're not putting anything very
fancy in here
I think there's some stuff that I'd have
to check to make sure it works like the
attach cells for the pre-flight things
yeah some of the cell selection stuff
you're doing to do the pre well but so
the basic scheme here will work in the
cloud and there's a value to having it
available in the cloud even if and and
we have a with the new design for the
menus we have a place to hang this on
the cloud okay and if necessary some
features might not be present on the
cloud yeah I could really make version
of this that works and right I mean the
the point about web forms and things is
that you know you need all the syntax
coloring you need the fact that you can
do evaluation and so it's basically a
notebook um and so we might as well make
it a notebook um alright so then we're
gonna follow through on this let me just
ask you about the submission process
here when used when people respond
within the company saying I can't find
the template notebook and things that's
really an inadequate response um what
are we doing for people who are actually
creating things right now
well we then create that eating our own
dog food thing I showed you the
beginning to get the old one
right it'll be in file new function
resources as well okay and but that's
coming in in the version twelve menu
there that's a much richer menu because
it has all kinds of things for all the
various repositories and so on is that
not correct right it's not know they're
level down I don't remember the details
but is it is it in that can I look at it
here as I don't now let's take a look we
open the ticket for
is it part I don't remember
yeah parth was carrying that for us so I
can check with him where it is yeah
that's not that's not adequate what's
that all right that doesn't even have
the lower there's second level though
right so we need to check that please
and that that should also be being
implemented in the cloud for version
1.50 okay so you need to check that also
or or 1.49 maybe make sense can you
somebody communicate with Matt yeah
figure that out okay I am now late for
the next thing here which we are also
live streaming um so okay let's look at
this again sometime
end of this week early next week make
sense
should hopefully be rather
straightforward yeah yep okay terrific
so people on the livestream thanks for
comments we are going to another live
stream if you want to hear about
annotation design thanks everybody